it opened its wings like this and
hovered above me screeching now you are
vampire and it was Peter the vampire is
perhaps the most universally
recognizable character in all of cinema
the most famous interpretation comes
largely from Bela Lugosi's jakela in
1931 where we got the classic accent and
widow's peak the high collar and cape
came from the vampire in theatres and
the sharp canines were popularized by
Christopher Lee's horror of Dracula
known as just Dracula in the UK in 1958
and it's a combination of these features
that leads us to the image of the
vampire were most familiar with it's the
vampire that shows up in cereal boxes
Geico commercials and Sesame Street
greetings I am the count but in reality
the design of the vampire varies
drastically depending on the movie count
or lock in Nosferatu looks like an evil
monster
but Edward Cullen in Twilight is
basically a perfect version of a human
each vampire is actually carefully
engineered to serve a certain purpose in
each movie and many scholars have
studied the meaning of different
vampires over time my name is Stanley
Stepanek I teach at the University of
Virginia I'm an associate professor
currently so I've taught a number of
things I've taught Russia and I'm
currently teaching the film course
Russian film Eastern European film but
my big course is called Dracula it's
about vampires and bunch of other things
there's been a fair amount of research
on the vampire in academia which makes
sense considering Dracula is the second
most popular character in cinematic
history behind only Sherlock Holmes and
that's not including the majority of
vampire films that don't even have a
Dracula s character one of the reasons
why the vampire is so popular amongst
filmmakers is its versatility as a
creature since the beginning of the
vampire on screen directors have always
made creative changes to their vampires
to suit their particular movie for
example the vampire spoke on Orlov
non-contracting an original and it comes
from the Dutch which means war you know
so obviously there's some connection
there with war and the loss of human
life in particular young men for Germany
during World War one in rest of all - so
war is obvious there yeah and it's also
clear symbol of like foreign
intervention or a fear of immigrants
Jewish immigration maybe or Jewish
influence and we know the unfortunate
tradition of that and you have this
thing that especially in that case which
is a human like but it's like it's so
foul looking at it spreads disease that
then it really reiterates the negative
connotations about being Jewish much of
the design of Count Orlok is
anti-semitic he has many features also
present in Jewish caricatures including
the association between Jewish people
and rats the filmmakers changed or
exaggerated some designs of the original
Dracula to make the creature more
relevant to the fears of post-world War
one Germany in particular they changed
the location because it's based in
Dracula they've changed it from
Transylvania to London Transylvania to
Germany right so obviously they're
making connections or their own collagen
or things that represent them yeah in
that case you know it's something to be
feared because what it's representing is
something that certain people lived in
like in short filmmakers always
customize their vampires to represent
something different Nosferatu was a way
to symbolize German fears at the time
that largely included anti-semitism but
the vampire can do much more than that
since vampires aren't technically human
directors have historically used them to
show behavior that would be too weird or
controversial if it were done by actual
humans in the 1930s homosexuality was
essentially banned on the big screen in
America by a series of moral guidelines
called the Hays Code but the vampire
found a way to work around that
starting with Dracula in 1931 vampires
quickly switched from disgusting
monsters of Count Orlok to sex symbols
like Bela Lugosi showing just how easily
the vampire can change and how the
vampire can mean something sexual some
of the images that that we have in
Western culture of things that are
horrific are also basically sexual
basically vampirism is just sex from the
neck up you're penetrating a passive
person it's just it really is a very
sexual sort of monster throughout the
filming of Dracula's daughter in 1936
Universal Pictures was well aware of the
lesbian implications of a female vampire
gazing at and biting a partially nude
woman
they changed the script to make Lily
clothed and had the camera cut away but
even with these changes the
homosexuality is pretty obvious
the vampire allowed a depiction of
lesbianism decades before humans could
do it themselves even though it isn't
explicit in zaleska is also interested
in guys in the film with vampires
controversial topics are much easier to
discuss when you compare movies about
the same topic that came out around the
same time vampires offer enough removal
from actual humans that they can go much
further with the topic Philadelphia is
about a homosexual suing a company for
wrongly terminating him because he has
AIDS as the first mainstream big-budget
movie focusing on a homosexual the movie
approaches the subject very carefully
and Rebecca is written very
sympathetically always nice and the
camera shows it nearly every scene gives
us a shot from his perspective with
close-ups and we even get home footage
to show how ordinary he is in contrast
the bad guys are filmed speaking almost
exclusively in racist and homophobic
slurs often shot from far away often
shot from behind Beckett doesn't express
his sexuality much he never kisses his
partner and the one scene showing two
men sharing a bed together was cut for
the theatrical release in many ways it
has to walk
down so many aspects of homosexuality to
show it as completely normal
you've survived what I assumed to being
a first gay party intact now I'm not
trying to say that Philadelphia should
have pushed more boundaries because then
it might not have done well during the
time that it came out what I am saying
is a vampire movie could do much more
interview with the vampire came out one
year later and there's an incredible
difference in how far it goes in
portraying homosexuality on screen it
goes further yeah yeah it shows you like
you know where they almost kiss and
stuff and gets really really you know
sexually tense in a number of scenes so
for example near the end whenever I'm on
just so you know with Lillian that art
gallery and Louise draws them really
close I mean they're like you know
they're that's close and then let's
start and the way he's connected to
Louie and then they get this daughter
you know I mean it's representing two
gay guys that have essentially adopted
like a child the back of nearly 90 is
like I can remember that being a
controversy I think this guy's but they
liked it right and again it's it makes
it like oh it's two vampires though
right you know it's it's it's like right
there but not officially saying it when
it's vampires you can hide your meaning
in a symbol then the movie can have more
nuanced characters and discussions the
movie doesn't need to have to give us
any lectures about homosexuality like
Philadelphia does interview with the
vampire marks the first piece of work
with a first-person perspective of the
vampire and it focuses more on the
relationship between vampires over time
not to mention the biting scenes are
extremely erotic more erotic than a
movie like Philadelphia was capable of
doing with real people but maybe my
favorite example of using a vampire to
be ahead of the times is death dream
originally titled dead of night a
lesser-known movie about a soldier who
dies in Vietnam and returns home as a
creature like a vampire
the director cleverly uses the vampire
to show what it was like for a veteran
to return home after combat as a totally
different person a shadow of their
former self like zombie like looking
corpse thing that is like near dad and
he yeah before he looks normal but he
wears his sunglasses how many acts we
heard out in public and his way of
responding is very dead like whenever
his ex-girlfriend or the girl used to
days talking to him you know that's that
one particular scene it's really telling
where she says you know I hope you're
not mad or anything he says
or anything it was a really dead
response as if he suck you know sort of
symbolizing that plight of the Vietnam
vet who's like emotionally dead as he
fights his friends and family his
actions directly mirror how Vietnam
veterans were rejected by society and
the media when they came back from war
it's a powerful message and the director
created a very human-like but
emotionally stunted kind of vampire to
show his message it's not much different
from a movie like Rambo but with a
vampire death dream came out eight years
before Rambo and just one year after the
Vietnam War in many ways the vampire
movies are ahead of the times the
vampire was also ahead of its time in
race relations the first black horror
movie was Blacula and it was a
box-office hit in the movie Dracula
strips Prince mama wall D of his power
when he tries to abolish the slave trade
cursing him as a vampire the movie
becomes a quest for Blacula to regain
his power and identity and he partially
does so by fighting off white policemen
attacking a black community here we see
a movie in 1972 already showing the
issues of racial profiling and the
fantasy of black Americans to fight back
making it way ahead of its time the
thing that makes that film boundary
breaking right is that you're getting
vampire but he likes it right so you
have some white people watching that and
then they identify with what's going on
eleven wall day and how that relates to
racial relations right whereas if you
showed you know a bunch of you know
african-americans attacking the place
then you make you probably have some
white people would be like I don't like
that same thing happens today whenever
the black lives matter talks about the
police intervention and black community
stuff like that but when you guys to
have a vampire in there sort of bridges
that gap and brings people together in a
different way
and so the modern vampire carries all
these past iterations of the vampire
with it this may seem silly to even talk
about but even a kid show on Disney
Channel uses the symbol of vampires to
talk about human issues
[Music]
I mean it's obvious right there what
that shows doing
it's basically symbolizing a different
culture or a different race their
character that's fun so that kids you
know can understand it better no I've
always thought they were the greatest
metaphor for the outsider in all of us I
felt like an outsider growing up a
misfit I think a lot of people did or do
at some time in their life feel like
outsiders outcasts and the vampire is a
great way to talk about that he's he's a
larger-than-life mythic hero who looks
human and can talk to you like a human
being but it's actually a monster he's
immortal he's outside of life and I
think that's a great metaphor for human
beings the show has episodes where
neighbors come to terms with the odd
vampire stereotypes this family follows
using a vampire makes it simple for kids
to understand and it's not controversial
it would be a little trickier to address
black or Asian stereotypes to a little
kid in a TV series but a fake creature
is a lot easier it's actually a great
example of why more complicated ideas
like homosexuality race relations in the
effects of war are more easily discussed
using a vampire instead of a human I'll
go for one more example that's a bit out
there why did Twilight do so well it's
definitely not the writing the book
copies a very common storyline in tons
of female young adult literature a story
of an attractive bad boy with a bad
background who is dangerous in some way
whether it's from drugs or abuse and he
meets a girl who changes him typically
it's through some very average girl that
he becomes a better person because of
love right and that's the idea that love
can change the world and there's this
guy out there that's gonna pick me right
no one else notices me and this guy's
gonna pick me and he's totally awesome
but I'm the one that's gonna lead to
that totally awesome because he's gonna
be another thing Twilight follows the
storyline extremely closely as have
dozens of novels before it but making
the bad boy a vampire is actually kind
of creative that creature is perfect for
that fantasy
they're usually attractive at least in
some modern movies they don't age and
they can't be killed but at the same
time vampires are dangerous they could
hurt you and they're extremely strong
there's that famous scene whenever
they're about the kids he jumps back
because he's afraid of going too far
because he could end up harming her
since she's you know human being it so
that danger that he represents is this
bad-boy image it's not really his fall
so to speak which is what makes him a
little more sellable too because he just
needs that we like to find the right
movie so that movie a novel craft a
vampire that works as a bad boy and
young girls identify with the girl
it's a fantasy for young girls that's
always been around but the vampire gives
it a new spin and allows the fantasy to
be explored a little deeper because at
the end of the day the bad boy fantasy
isn't real that's not how real life
works so using a fake creature instead
of a human lets you go further with the
fantasy just like you can with other
complicated issues as a great sum up of
vampires over time the comedy what we do
in the shadows helps us understand the
power of the vampire as a symbol over
all the vampires in the movie are all
from different time periods and
influences Peters terrifying monster
portrayal echos Count Orlok in Nosferatu
Vladislav seems influenced by vladislav
and Dracula and Nic has similarities to
Edward from Twilight even admitting it
himself
you say as a mockumentary we follow
around these vampires in their everyday
lives and in a weird way the format and
style actually teaches us a lot about
vampires in media we get documentaries
when we think about it it's worthy of a
documentary so make it about a serious
good product and therefore you'll learn
about the nature of the product by
studying this serious this film it is
really doing something quite special
it's saying you can learn just as much
by studying something lousy when you're
a vampire you become very sexy this
movie shows us what it would really be
like if vampires existed it wouldn't be
epic like in all these other movies it
would actually be ridiculous they would
have to find a place to live they would
have to clean their flat and biting
someone wouldn't always be dramatic and
theatrical sometimes it would just be
silly what we do in the shadows shows
how every other vampire movie
artificially creates a vampire to suit
their own meaning by showing us every
vampire in film history in one movie we
realise just how different they all are
and it's true some vampires look
disgusting to show fears of disease and
anti-semitism some are basically perfect
versions of humans and there's
everything in between and the traits of
the vampire always means something it
represents not really human problems in
a way that makes it accessible to the
spawn
vampires are fun and it makes it
indirect so that it's kind of safer to
discuss it you know when you're talking
about a vampire that symbolizes racial
identity instead of talking about those
issues directly and that little bit of
distance from actual humans that's the
vampire really pushed boundaries and be
ahead of its time so the next time you
watch a vampire movie maybe you can see
a powerful message based on what they do
or don't do vampires don't do dishes and
maybe you'll learn about vampires in a
new and different way which is what
these videos are supposed to be all
about I like this table etiquette
students like it stuff more and you know
it's it's encapsulate some more
information to share now stays so it's
where things are going but it's in
academia just doesn't want to shift yeah
it's starting to but it really needs to
you know one of the most important
novels for the vampire is I am Legend
the original book has the first
scientific vampire one that's not
supernatural but caused by an actual
disease it's a big influence for Night
of the Living Dead a movie that paved
the way for the modern zombie so yes
that means the zombies we see today
partially originate from vampires you
can listen to this book today using
audible and I really recommend you check
it out
the original book is so much better than
the Will Smith movie version in 2007 go
to audible.com slash now you see it to
get a 30-day trial in your first
audiobook for free or text now you see
it to five hundred five hundred to get
started audible content includes an
unmatched selection of audiobooks
original audio shows news comedy and
more from the leading audio book
publishers broadcasters entertainers
magazine and newspaper publishers and
business information providers audible
really does make commuting bearable
maybe even enjoyable if you get the
right book I am Legend definitely works
so go to audible.com slash now you see
it for the free trial and any audiobook
for free or text now you see it to five
hundred five hundred to get started
thanks for watching